it's a continual like suspense continual
suspense is what we're going for it Oh
excellent connection there's a button to
press any strings that's promising I
feel like oh that's a good time yeah now
we're live this is our first street live
stream so if we have a few little
teething problems I'm sure you'll be
patient yeah we were just playing guitar
for the last five minutes so that we
because we never know with a live stream
if it's live and like when you actually
try to get it live or five minutes later
but here we are yeah here we are so the
motivation for this live stream was that
last year I did a video which was the
science of 2018 and it was a lot of work
and I feel like it would I just felt
like it would suit a lot better to a
live stream where it could be
interactive we take a look at all of the
science stories of the last year and the
way this is gonna work is we've gone and
taken there's this really good page on
Wikipedia which is called the size of
2019 we've gone through that we've
extracted all of the best science
content they lots of different
categories so I've got a piece of paper
here yeah these are the categories you
can choose from so we're going to ask
you to vote on what you want first and
then we'll take it in terms we've each
got we've done the research with the
research between ourselves and so we'll
take over and explain exactly like all
of our favorite science stories of the
year and for me I think there's a lot of
negative news that goes around I don't
know if you've noticed that but
sometimes when you go on news or social
media it tends to be a bit of a bummer
yeah like oh man the world is is a bit
bad but actually and even as someone
that follows
snooze like there's so many amazing
science discoveries and like science
findings that I never even heard about
that are like wow like people are doing
amazing things that's pretty uplifting
so yeah
Dom's idea is to share those findings
with the world so yeah yeah because it's
an antidote I think to normal news is
looking at the advance of people making
insides really I found at least when I
was doing this research really
optimistic and uplifting and just
amazing to see that we're actually are
making a lot of progress is that human
race so it's kind of like an antidote to
all of that news
so yeah I'm stoked I'm not surprised but
if you're looking at the comments at all
everyone wants physics or space okay
physics this is obviously on Tom's
Channel okay yeah so why don't we start
the voting I'm going let's go through
all the categories
yes we have human evolution or evolution
space artificial intelligence genetics
climate change technology can I do this
yeah I can't blow medicine and my
favorite subject physics oh I tell you
what we should do while you vote
everyone's voting to physics genetics
physical space shout out to me please
math physics physics will spit I think
yeah I think I think what we should do
so we'll do physics I just thought we
had introduced ourselves because we have
actually done that yet so presumably a
lot of people know who we are but if
you're new I'm Dominic Waterman I do
this channel domain of science my
background is in physics mostly so
physics is my subject plus a bit of
computer science plus quite a lot of
quantum computing plus a bit of machine
learning my name is Curtis Bodi and I
run the YouTube channel Curtis Bodi I do
over-the-top science experiments I do a
lot of videos about the environment
because it's something I care a lot
about
it's what I did my masters of science in
and I did a degree in biology before
that so we're gonna have like physics
over on this side and like biology on
this side roughly speaking sounds great
okay and excited to be here let's get
cracking okay we're gonna do physics
physics and cross off the physics well
I'll be proud of myself
get marker on my arm during this go see
okay okay so well we should say there
are this is gonna be a marathon oh yes
to cover we trying to write as much as
possible we try to you know suss out
what is happening in each of these but
we may get things wrong and we apologize
yes there's a very good disclaimer
obviously we are coming to a lot of
these subjects from from like Outsiders
trying to glean the information from the
news reports and so we've got a Google
Doc where we've actually done all of our
research I think we'll share that at the
end of the stream so that in the future
you can go and have a look at all the
original articles of this and which I
really recommend doing but let's crack
into em I'll try not to take too long so
let's see so first article is scientists
unveil the first image of quantum
entanglement and so I don't know how
much to say about this but quantum
entanglement is a feature of quantum
mechanics which gives quantum mechanics
it's some of its strange behaviors and
it's of interest because it's used in
quantum technologies like quantum
computing and also it's the fundamental
nature of how the universe works so it's
like a good thing to work out and in
this paper what they managed to do was
[Music]
capturing an image of quantum
entanglement yes is that one of those
like you can't if you look at it
directly you're like messing with it
things yeah exactly so the thing in
quantum mechanics is if you set up a
quantum state so a quantum entanglement
is you have two separate particles you
bring them together their properties
overlap so now that those two separate
entities become one entity you need to
describe them all in terms of quantum
mechanics you need to describe them all
as one thing so in entanglement what
that means is you can then take those
two things far away from each other
even millions of miles away or
kilometers we are in Canada and if you
measure one of those you immediately
know the state of the other one and so
it's a thing that freaked out in static
because its instantaneous action at a
distance and said it was spooky action
at a distance and so this is one of
those things as soon as you measure it
it actually collapses so it's cool so
they've managed to do this okay should
we go to the next one yeah so all right
it's working
this is good cool so Fusion Energi is
obviously cool if we keep if we can
solve fusion energy it will actually
solve the energy crisis what is fusion
energy okay oh yeah that's a good idea
yeah so fusion power comes from so
you've got a power station it uses
fusion fusion reaction which is a
nuclear reaction is what the Sun does
hydrogen helium smash it together you
make a heavier thing with you more
something and then energy comes out and
you can use that as energy to boil water
every Power Station you just boil water
and it's been something that's been
something which it seems like maybe we
could come up with a better knowledge to
do that but nope it's still like steam
so if you the trouble with infusion
power in fusion reactors is that in the
Sun the reason that the Sun can keep
fusion power going is because you've got
the pressure of the entire mass of the
Sun pushing it in and kind of containing
the reaction so the Sun is like a
continual hydrogen bomb so like a
nuclear bomb continually exploding the
reason it doesn't just explode accents
so much stuff it squeezes it in you're
trying to maintain that stable e with
inner nuclear reactor and that's really
really hard because these things are at
such high energies you don't have the
pressure of the Sun to contain it and so
maintaining the fusion reaction you need
to do with very precise magnetic fields
and that's hard to do and so in this
advanced they've managed to actually
stabilize that nuclear reaction using I
think it was it was some kind of
electromagnetic wave yeah using radio
waves radio waves right that's it
small changes of the temperature of the
plasma to control it more they're
basically creating a Sun like it's very
similar right it took the same it's the
exactly the same physics yeah it might
be it's the reaction that's powering the
Sun which if we can harness it on earth
it would be completely transformative
fingers crossed I mean if this has been
like since the yeah I don't know when it
started but yeah certainly 70s or even
it but we're finally getting to the
point where it's like it's really close
yeah so so notable things that happened
recently I think it was about four years
ago they had the first reaction where
they got more energy out than they put
in and so that was a landmark which
didn't get much coverage but that was
one of those points where you're like
okay now we've done the experiment where
we can
you get more more energy out than we put
in which is yeah anyway
I'll move on so that's a cool thing
fusion power a little bit closer
generator okay so this is generating
power from a nuclear basically a
radioactive element called an MMO a
qiyam americium okay I've been
memorizing all of the elements thanks I
would have called it americium but no
I'm pretty I'm sure you are yes what
country it's named after okay sorry
murky could just call it murky um there
so this is from nuclear fusion powers
which is the opposite of sorry nuclear
fission power which is the opposite to
nuclear fusion where you take big atoms
like uranium you split my palm or Pluto
in this case you take plutonium you
split it apart and you get um hariki and
what you can do is because it's
radioactive is continuing giving out
heat again you can use that heat to
generate electricity and the first
battery made on this material was made
and there the hope from this is to
create batteries that could power things
like spacecraft for I think they were
saying 400 years so from this one tiny
battery which is obviously useful for
deep-space missions where you're going
far away from the Sun and your solar
powers but panels don't work anymore so
that's cool another one excitons pave
the way to more efficient electronics
okay
controlling excitons is a new kind of
technology it sounds exciting
I just don't know what an exciton okay
is it like a quark it's smaller than a
quark it is something different
oh no it's bigger than
okay I'll explain as much the note so an
exciton is when you've gone Adam Adams
got electrons around them and you can
excite those electrons into higher
energy states by shining lasers on them
the then what happens is that creates a
hole in the atom of a position or I
should you use my use my little space at
window for my hands gestures it creates
a little hole in the atom where it's
like a vacancy for an electron and then
the excited electron is now creating
well the excited electron is paired with
that hole and so the exciton is the pair
of those two things so what you can do
is you can actually use this as a kind
of switch in electronics so you can make
it excitons and then if you can
manipulate them you can move them around
and do things with them it's kind of
like electronics and so the hope of this
is that you can make a transistor where
current transistors you need to encode a
0 or a 1 in a chip and currently what
they do is that you need to have a
little movement of current to flip it
from a 0 or a 1 with this one you could
do it with like a laser pulse which
would be a lot lower power and so that's
the hope of this so this is a cool
advance so everything is better with
lasers it's yeah including seabass
that's cool ok the SI units got
redefined so the International System of
Units is how we define everything else
how we do science the accuracy of these
units how we do so so things like the
kilogram the meter what are they all
like let's see if that's based well this
speed of light actually defines the meat
we've got the kilogram we've got the
meter we've got the second that's time
yeah time is the second
we've got Candela which is a measure of
luminosity we've got the mole which is a
measure of amount of substance
seven Oh temperature yes the Kelvin oh
wait they're on this they're on this
picture and lamp air that's electricity
and so these are you would have got it
yeah they said this is the set of units
that we've chosen to pin down and all
other units like energy or magnetic
field or any of those any other units
that we use in in science are all based
on these but for science to work we need
to know exactly how long a meter is or
how heavy a kilogram is and this
redefinition is really important because
it's we've managed to eliminate all
physical so we used to have a standard
mass which was a literal physical lump
of metal that we were like this is a
kilogram yeah it was called the big
kilogram yeah in French and they had
many copies of this kilogram which
they'd store around the world but the
trouble is they kept drifting away from
each other because they were absorbing
carbon from the air mass was drifting
yeah their mass was drifting and so then
he had many different and the read only
base slight amounts like atomic weights
but this is important because if you're
trying to design incredibly accurate
scientific experiments on these
definitions of things like mass if
you've got different masses and they're
drifting away from each other that
actually affects the it's the baseline
of the quality of the results that you
it actually matters sorry I'm just gonna
yeah I'm glad you're doing it because
normally that's I'm doing too much where
is it yeah like in old experiments too
we we have the values like we had
Eratosthenes measure of the size of the
earth but since he was using using units
that were like the stadium the size of a
stadium for distance like we don't know
what his results actually were but these
results matter like knowing knowing the
unit is what it all comes down to so
that's really cool yeah so they defined
the color yeah region
and they've no longer is it based on
physical maths now it's based on
Planck's constant and that's the last
unit yeah that's the last one so they're
all I actually want to do a video on
this so subscribe to my channel because
in the future if you're interested in
this there'll be a video on it so ok
let's move on
IBM unveils its first commercial quantum
computer I've got some welcome to
computing stuff in the technology
section so I'll probably wait until that
it looks cool
scientists break the wreck of the
highest-ever superconductor ok so this
happens just about every year actually
we have some record-breaking result in
superconducting well maybe not every
year but there's there's very often
stories so that the hope and dream of
condensed matter physicists who are the
people who work on superconductors is to
make a room-temperature superconductor
because it means that we could transmit
electricity across the globe without
losing any energy whatsoever it would be
a hundred percent efficient and this one
is negative at the temperature of
negative 23 degrees Celsius which is
like I would have followed the way
colder than that yeah I know that's like
you can put that in Canada yeah you
could just put that inside if you made a
computer out of that you could just
literally put it in a refrigerator and
it would it would not lose any energy
now the trouble is there's always a
caveat the only way you can get these
very high temperature superconductors is
by pressurizing them so you physically
squeeze the material to within some
diamonds and when you squeeze it you
change the material properties of the
electrons in that material so that's how
you get those high temperature
superconductors but the aim is to
hopefully make use these as information
to work out whether there is a way that
we can have a normal material at room
temperature that exhibits
superconductivity and this will
hopefully give us some more information
that
okay we found a new kind of light which
I have to admit I don't fully understand
it but when light interacts with
insulators I think or semiconductors
very close to the surface of those you
get a new kind of light which is called
this diagonal void waves which sound
cool sounds like something out of a
Marvel movie the amazing thing about
physics to me is that this was first
like this was suggested in the equations
of Maca Clerk James Clerk Maxwell yeah
in the mid-1800s yeah like a hundred
twenty seventy years ago something like
that yeah Wow discovering it yeah that's
cool so the implications of the extra my
electromagnetism discovered by him still
haven't been fully investigated so this
is cool I don't know what the
applications of this are but that would
be cool to know maybe it's in the
article okay this is this is an example
of a measurement type experiment problem
so physicists finally nailed the proton
size and hope dies I'm not sure why hope
dies so this was a cool experiment basic
question how big is a proton right you'd
think we would know
turns out until recently we didn't know
and the the way you find there are two
two experiments you can do to find out
the radius of a proton so what you do is
you take a hydrogen atom and you put it
in a certain energy state where the
electron actually exists for a certain
amount of time within the proton so
inside the nucleus because in quantum
mechanics electrons are in a specific
place they are a probability of
three-dimensional probability waves so
the probability of the electron can go
inside the proton and by looking at
this thing called I think the lamb shift
which is like a very fine energy spectra
of the of the atoms you can do some
physics and maths and you can determine
the the radius of the proton so you can
do that and then what you can do is you
can take hydrogen and instead of having
an electron change that out for a muon
which behaves just like an electron got
the same charge but it's got a different
mass and so then it squeezes it the the
probability cloud is a lot smaller
closer to the proton and so it's got
more probability of being inside the
proton and so you can get an accurate
more accurate measure of the size of the
proton so what they did is they did
these two experiments and they got
different results for the size of the
proton so this is back in the day now
recently what they did was they repeated
that measurement of the size of the
proton using electrons and they found
I've actually agreed with the muon
resolves so before when they disagreed
they thought are there some new physics
here but now that they agree they're
like okay those old experiments were
actually wrong so they're old
experiments the size of a proton using
electron we're incorrect so this is what
they found
so we've refined it yeah so we've
refined it this is still served progress
it's not the most sort of like
revolutionary thing like making fusion
power work but still it's cool
understanding what the size of the
proton is is very important thing I
always just like to click classify when
people say like oh we were wrong
we don't mean like if there is no proton
we mean like we're more precise now yeah
yeah exactly that's cool yeah that's
super cool ok and that's it for physics
for this year physics is crossed off ok
so no more physics ok it's done for 2019
so need another we need another vote
which is up to you so which category
would like to see next human evolution
in space artificial intelligence a
musical in saliva change technology
chemistry those are at the options we're
gonna go with whatever we see happening
in the comments we're gonna get a cool
guitar groove happening again one for
space
[Music]
I'm sorry it's not a secret vote climate
change all right
power to that second space human so
space is the only one I've seen two of
now Jenna expenses three for space three
for genetics we're getting a lot of
genetics think of genetics movie let's
do now we're gonna love this place we'll
do genetics yeah let's do genetics sorry
space people will get to space we
promise back oh this is weird
there we go we're doing we're doing good
medics that's right good enhancing sauce
okay
this is a cracker ouch you won't be
disappointed yeah there's a lot of
amazing and like kind of horrifying
stuff happened all at the same time I
gotta open now I full and go to this
there we go
I've subcategorized each of my
categories or subtitled them genetics is
let's get weird question mark because
it's odd so okay so for the first thing
there's a lot of I mean most of the
genetics we do happens in plants which
is important because we need them to
live we eat plants or we eat things that
eat plants so scientists recently
figured out how to make photosynthesis
more efficient photosynthesis the thing
that allows plants to eat sunlight and
carbon dioxide in the air it's actually
really really inefficient it just
evolved pretty randomly and it actually
throws out most of the energy that it
gets and you've probably seen that in
highschool
Rubisco that really complicated chart so
anyway they've basically the long story
short in this is that they designed a
new plant that is 40% yeah that is 40%
more productive in terms of its
photosynthetic rate which is super cool
because that means that we're gonna have
advancements coming in the agriculture
as the population of the planet grows so
that's neat
next up very cool
this is wild this is a something that
happened this year that I didn't even
know though which is I mean I love
genetics so it's it's shocking that they
slipped through as the title says freaky
eight-letter DNA could be the stuff of
edible aliens title is weird but
scientists created normally DNA is made
with four bases four letters as you
might say and scientists recently
created a genetic code that used eight
that they could put information into
which is really really cool because I
mean the more letters you have basically
the more information you're able to
encode in the same amount of stuff so
that's wild the another cool thing about
this is that it proved also so in
addition to being great for data storage
it also proved that there's other
possibilities from what DNA could look
like
so as this title suggests maybe aliens
have different DNA than we do and I
would think they would also it's just
it's just really neat yeah just the idea
that you could store information in DNA
so from a computer point of view if
you're gonna make a long-term storage of
information like we know all of our
things most people have had a hard drive
fell on them and computer memory just
degrades over time DNA has been
maintaining itself through biological
processes but billions of years so if we
want some kind of long-term storage of
their like DNA is like a really good
thing it's fantastic and something that
I mean we don't really know too much
about where this will go just yet but
it's possible that since it doesn't
interact with viruses and bacteria like
normal DNA would it might be even better
for DNA storage which is really really
cool because nothing's evolved around
things in don't attack it like they do
normal and didn't they encode Wikipedia
into it that's the next thing so I think
that this was done with with regular DNA
no it wasn't it was with the synthetic
DNA sunscreen scientists encoded all of
Wikipedia into DNA which is mind-blowing
the rate at which they can encode
information is also super fast and if
you think about like we're just figuring
out how to do this and it already is at
where is the information is that four
megabits per second right into DNA
that's wild that's like a phone call
when you're calling and it's the DNA
according what you're saying that's
amazing what yeah so and and Wikipedia
for the record is huge at 16 gigabytes
and I did the math that's about 53,000
books worth of information in and you
could fit that in a single cell which
you couldn't see obviously it's like
that's incredible so that's very cool
it's really exciting it's like a blimp
so physics is always a glimpse into the
near future like fusion power and
software I find genetic engineering is
always fortunately yeah this is kind of
biological stuff is also it would
glimpse into this crazy future where
we've got bio computers that are just
weird like cells growing out our brain
interfacing with our minds and creating
super brain humans so I'm probably going
off on that's there that's a little bit
sci-fi but it might be possible at some
day and that's really in at the very
least for storing information like this
could be something that we have in the
future like we you know we sit we store
instead of having to back up all our
hard drives we just have a little tumor
and it's all in there you know I don't
know we'll see it's exciting though
search and replace everything okay so
this is like you need to know a little
bit about how about--how genome editing
works so everyone has a genome it's all
your genes all the information that
makes you up and scientists basically
made this really big breakthrough in
editing a genome without having to
basically so so DNA is these two two
strands the double helix and scientists
figured out how to
and find a piece of information in that
code and replace it without breaking
those two strands apart which is
normally how it's done which is really
exciting it means that there's like an
entirely new type of genetic information
encoding that you could that we might be
able to do soon
you've heard of CRISPR Katz 9 it's like
that but hopefully even better that's
the idea yeah that was like when I read
this I was like whoa something better
than crisper because CRISPR has been
seen as this amazing technology but as
people have researched it they found
this significant issues if things aren't
edited correctly you can have mistakes
that happen far away from the place that
you're actually doing editing so it's
kind of cool that there's another
technology come along and this might not
even be the end you know there's going
to be more advances in these techniques
so that's very cool yeah and oh yeah and
in this is if it's the right one g8 no
that's further up ok is that oh yeah and
they call this prime editing which i
think is really really kind of great as
a title I think that's it for two
minutes no there's more there's more I'm
just I got this oh I didn't I wasn't
keeping up with this oh yeah yeah oh
yeah so this is Wikipedia
I just didn't move forward in the right
way you know so Wikipedia we talked
about that okay so this is get achill
cringy side of what's happening so we've
moved from the comics oh yeah cool to
the what are they doing is this okay so
so we've started we as in humanity our
species has started to do all sorts of
cloning experiments including the first
cloned end gene edited monkeys which is
kind of wild so the idea for this
experiment is that we do a lot of
research using monkeys because they're
very similar to us broadly speaking and
what we won the scientists wanted to
have a set of monkeys that were
identical so that they could do very
specific controlled experiments on them
and have them all be the same
but and they did that and this is what
they've done in China the problem is
that obviously this is a bit of an
ethical mess because they're basically
making cloned sick monkeys and like I
don't know if we're really ready to be
messing with like DNA at that level I
mean like the whole primate family is
really intelligent I feel weird when
they're even in cages but anyway yeah I
mean it this whole area I've not had to
do anything personally weird yeah so
like I understand the arguments that in
animal models for testing drugs it's a
necessary thing to test it in before you
move on to humans so in clinical trials
of drugs we wouldn't have the drugs that
we have today that are saving lots of
people's lives with our animal models
the trouble is is that you're totally
right about using primates to do this is
like they're very I mean they're very
close to humans which is why they're
attractive to use in these experiments
but then yeah from a moral point of view
normally normally when doing any sort of
biology research that involves animals
there is a huge ethical like a bunch of
steps you need to go through to make
sure that it's going to be okay and
there's actually like a board of ethics
that you have to get approval from yeah
but in some countries this is done a
little bit differently we're gonna see
another story that is similar and then
we're going to follow one story in
particular for a bit of a that thread
first monkey slash pig chimera which is
basically when you have two species
combined into one genetically was
created in China so this is another
pretty wild story
it's basically what it says they're
mostly as you can see in the image it is
mostly pig they have I think one less
than 1% of their DNA is from a monkey
but this is like the first time
well I think one of the first times in
mammal is where we've done like
cross-species taking DNA from one mammal
and putting it into another which is
pretty wild something that they never
find in any sort of cloning or genetics
study which I always find shocking is
the amount of attempts that it takes in
order to get all these good right
so it took I didn't even I think yeah
they grew only one human cell okay might
not that so it took four thousand
embryos to get two of these chimeras so
it took like Alana this took a lot of
pigs and I don't really know if there is
a good point as to why they did this I'm
not sure what the actual goal was I know
that long term we're hoping to get like
we're hoping to make improvements and
how we get organ transplants and organ
donors it would be nice if we could
I mean I'm vegan but it would be nice if
we could have organ donations from an
animal that we could grow so the idea
was idea okay the idea would be say grow
a human kidney in a pig and then harvest
it okay which is kind of weird but
anyway this is like a reached there was
a lot of criticism and the scientific
community does yes okay but not as much
as the following one which has happened
last year and then is continuing to be a
bit of a mess this year there was a
researcher a research lab in China that
created CRISPR human twins so
genetically modified humans last year
and even the like the Chinese government
was like whoa you liked we did not give
you approval for this like what is going
on and then researchers this year
separate research was this year figured
out that they probably had their brains
like accidentally enhanced and like
we're not really going to know what that
means until these people grow up this
makes these little freaks me except the
goal for this experiment was to modify
humans to these these two excuse me
these two twins to not
HIV because there's a gene that prevents
you from getting HIV and so they had
that but they also might have had their
brains accidentally enhance which is
like a sign that maybe we don't quite
know enough about what we're doing to be
able to do this stuff like let's just
slow down I know it's yeah this is the
good scientific consensus on all of this
stuff is like you did what there's way
too early to start doing this on human
yeah cuz yeah I mean it it doesn't take
much to understand the ethical problem
with creating human beings who have had
genetic me agita genomes
yeah yeah and then next up this is a big
this story followed that same thread the
same yeah and it made it made really big
news but I think it's something that
also happens in science that I wanted to
address really quickly there was another
study that came out saying that not only
did they probably have their brains
edited but they probably have shorter
lifespans and then we did more research
about that research and we redacted or
we sort of retracted that paper so just
saying that whatever you see in the news
as science news it can take time to be
verified or discredited so that's why
we're doing on the end of your wrap-up
that paper was taken away so they maybe
don't have shorter lifespans but I still
probably shouldn't do it anyway it's in
that Wikipedia article and I'll make an
edit to it cool okay and then we get to
pick a new category ooh
genetics what do we got okay we have
still would you like to do a musical
interlude well I can do that yeah that's
we have human evolution space artificial
intelligence climate change technology
chemistry and medicine
that's got lots of space they see space
from here oh you see spies enough I
think mine's updating slower than yo
space base everyone space okay okay
let's go to space let's go to space you
gotta cross that one up I'll bring this
up great and I'll switch this hello to
everyone in the chat by the way if
you've joined us since the beginning I
said welcome in and out made a door
donation thank you Oh a while ago but I
wanted to still say it loud go into
space here we go
this is cool this is this is also cool
is there's also quite a long one so I'll
see if I can rattle through it but okay
first story which you all saw I did a
video on this we haven't seen that go
check that yeah
first image of a black hole and
technically it's not actually of the
black hole it's of the emissions from
the gas around the black hole but
essentially it's it's of the black I
mean the thing in the middle here is
where the black hole lives and the
technology around this was really cool
so it was done using a bunch of radio
telescopes I think it was the let's just
get up my informations here the black
hole is 54 million light years away 54
million light years away we find the
event horizon telescope project was the
project that did it involves collecting
the data from so they're radio
telescopes so they see in the radio
waves which are very long wavelengths
and they used a collection of multiple
telescopes all around the world
combined the information from all of
those together to make an effective
telescope the size of the earth so
basically we turn the entire earth into
a radio telescope that allowed us to
resolve things as small as is this and
this is like way smaller than dimensions
that the hubble space telescope couldn't
see so this is very very cool black
holes are interesting because what for
many reasons the most extreme objects we
have in the universe they at the center
of them they've got a gravitational
singularity
they're so massive and dense that they
rip a hole in space-time and the laws of
Einstein's theory of general relativity
completely break down so basically they
are our hole in our knowledge of physics
there's firmly in the chasm of ignorance
and the other reason why they're really
really interesting is because we have a
big problem in in physics which is we
don't know how to mash together our
understanding of the large things which
is gravity Einstein's theory of general
relativity with our understanding of
very smallest things which is quantum
mechanics I'm just here for justice
because those two things don't interact
very much atoms don't really experience
gravity very strongly because they've
got hardly any maths and big things
don't exhibit the properties of quantum
mechanics by entanglement and
superposition those things I saw earlier
but you do get them both appearing in
black holes because black holes are so
massive in their curving space-time so
much that now that is actually the
interface between well it's the one
object that we know of where where those
two things meet so the surface of a
black hole the thing that Stephen
Hawking got incredibly famous for
Hawking radiation was he actually put
together the laws of general relativity
with laws of quantum mechanics and saw
what happened and there are a few
different models
black holes we still don't know how they
work we don't know if they destroy
information like a normal description of
a black hole is that it destroys
everything that goes into it but the
trouble is in quantum mechanics you
can't destroy information so they're a
puzzle and stuff like this will give us
more information about how black holes
work and hopefully in the future black
holes might be the key to unlocking a
grand general theory of physics where
we'll understand everything you know I
thought this was just cool because it
taught us about black holes and realize
that that's awesome yeah it's a very
cool stuff and the technology behind it
is cutting-edge and amazing - next story
fast radio bursts so this is also in the
in the realm of radio astronomy looking
from signals in outer space with very
long wavelengths and this is really
interesting because we don't know what's
creating these signals at all and what
we know is they're from very far away
they're from some Astrophysical event
which is incredibly high energy we don't
know what is causing that and at the
start of this year we had seen some fast
radio bursts and we'd seen one which
repeated which was quite a shock because
normally high-energy events in in the
depths of space only happen for a single
event like a supernova or a collision of
neutron stars or a neutron star falling
into a black hole
something like that that only happens
once what's weird about these fast radio
bursts is they happen over and over and
over again so they're repeating by the
end of this year we found 10 so now we
know about 10 of these fast radio bursts
repeating fast radio bursts some repeat
slow period some are quite quick and I
think they're not all so it's not like a
ticking of a clock they happen with
and times so we're thinking maybe go to
other fast radio bursts that we've only
seen one event of maybe those are
actually repeating which is haven't
looked at them for long enough and
what's called as this is still a mystery
we don't know what is causing me
probably not aliens do you like every
time it's aliens and we're like actually
it's this natural causing in the chat
tell me if you think it's alien I mean
you're asking I'll be disappointed if
they don't say just joined in so next
story what is this I can't remember what
this is let me have a look on my list
new study reveals the extent of
underground water on Mars okay this is
Mars water okay a few different cool
results have occurred over the last year
Mars water so one we know that there
used to be own I've got ink on my thumb
we know that they used to be ground
water on Mars a series of reservoirs
that we've detected the signal which is
with these results that you're seeing on
the screen there and we've seen like
ancient signs of water like of lakes
there's yeah this is the ancient so
they're dried up now there's no water on
in them now but we've got this signature
that they used to be lots of reservoirs
of water on Mars and so that's true
facts there's a indication also
separately from this that there could
still be underground water reservoirs
how we do on the aliens
it's lots of aliens okay so we've got an
indication that maybe even nowadays
there are liquid water under the surface
of Mars it's not shown to be proven to
be correct but we've detected some thing
is it the New Horizons spacecraft I
don't remember and this is like very
briny water but water which would be
cool and this is important because
we went to Mars well two things right
this is important because if we went to
Mars we could get water out of the soil
basically and wherever we look for water
on earth we find life so potentially
maybe Yogi's could be but for real like
a microcellular aliens yeah it was the
insight Lander
which landed on Mars that discovered
some magnetic incongruities does no not
evidence but that's one explanation so
it seemed just interesting for the
future that future space missions could
actually target that but to see if
that's okay Scott Kelly spent a year in
orbit his body's not quite the same so
this was the twins study by NASA and
they were looking at what changes
happened when you send one twin into
space and keep one of the twins on earth
and see what changes so the change is
that they found were that persistent
changes were observed even after six
months including some genes expression
levels increased DNA damage from
chromosomal inversions I don't know what
that is you know a chromosomal inversion
is yeah I think it's when the
chromosomes chromosomes are like a
tangled mess and they can basically
touch each other and have gene swap over
pretty sure it's been a while since that
yeah yeah increased numbers of short
telomeres which is how our cell cells
age I believe and in attenuated
cognitive functions going into space is
actually like a bit of a rough time when
your body surprised about i mean you
ride a giant explosive off the planet
into a radiation zero-gravity yeah and
then you're also like really do do you
do all the experiments and work super
hard there it's no shock but that's into
it that's cool that think I can actually
like experiment with this with two with
two twins
yeah and the experiments are obviously
really useful for long-term space
exploration
we want to go to Mars if you want to
settle on Mars all of this stuff is
really good to know most of the news is
not good though so they've done other
studies on people's biology so there was
they also found this year that dormant
viruses in the body might get activated
in space
so you've got viruses in your body that
are not doing anything but you're in
space and they're they start being
active wonder what's causing that like
if it's because your body's stressed out
gotta send more into space yeah I can do
it
also astronauts on the International
Space Station are more prone to blood
clots which is not a good thing
astronauts experience serious blood flow
Stacy
so basically blood stasis where your
blood is not moving around your body I
guess we're used to gravity pushing
blood downwards and then we pump it back
up again so blood being in stasis is
where isn't just not moving through the
blood vessels which means that is more
more prone to clotting dangerous space
is dangerous yeah so for long for long
distance missions I think we're just
gonna have to have some kind of
microgravity or so I'm like spinning
thing kind of like in mm oh one okay
cool
next mission unusual super rare winter
the collapse of the star oh yes so this
is an event which I reported on last
year in my wrap-up of science of the
year which is very amusingly named
eighty 2018 cow and sea co w always
first name and it was a very powerful
astronomical explosion 110 to 100 times
brighter than a normal supernova so it
was an insanely bright supernova which
we didn't quite know what was causing
this again it was like so powerful that
we didn't know what it was we now think
that it was it could have been a white
dwarf star being pulled
a black hole I'm so glad we're long way
away yes okay that's just one stupid
humanist object I think this might be
the same one like a start yeah that's
like the same oh yeah this was the sad
news of the year the opportunity Rover
finally gave up the ghost after 15 years
sad but not like I feel like that's like
a cause for celebration
yeah not that it died but that it black
it was supposed to last like 15 years so
that's very cool
hopefully curiosity will keep going for
as long we could on the old just to
bring up the aliens topic again this is
positive results showing how life on
Earth is resilient life on Earth is to
being exposed to empty space so in this
study they put on the International
Space Station they put extremophiles
archaea bacteria so anti bacteria algae
black fungi and all sorts of other
things out into space and they
discovered that all of these different
microorganisms showed some level of
survival and the best survival was
amongst archaea bacteria fungi and
biofilms so in space in yeah being the
vac you exposed to the vacuum of space
life can exist which is super cool and
like interesting because like rocks
transfer between planets and asteroids
and all the time like we regularly get
asteroids that have been parts of Mars
that have been broken off of Mars and
flown into space and landed here like
that happens so maybe life could hitch a
ride which is pretty neat that we have
like evidence that that's pause
yeah it's just has to go through the
atmosphere which is super hot but some
of those archaea are known to do that so
that's really it's just very cool that
all of this happened this year I have to
keep reminding myself this is just this
year okay we found more moons of Saturn
so now Saturn has got more moons than
Jupiter so I didn't know that 82 moons
Jupiter has got 79 that's cool
we found buckyballs in inter spelling to
spell interstellar space
so buckyballs of this configuration of
carbon molecules look at carbon atoms or
it into a molecule that resembles kind
of like a soccer ball and we found that
those five forming interstellar space
which is cool yeah we did a survey of
the mass of the Milky Way galaxy
we've now it's twice as heavy as we used
to think or twice as massive I should
say and 90% of our galaxy is made of
dark matter so much so I saw with some
people in the chat earlier asking what
dark matter is so I'll just explain dark
matter quickly at least what we know of
it
so it would take me days when we look
into deep space and we see galaxies they
form these spirals in these clusters
which they and you can watch them
spinning at a certain rate now spinning
things tend to fly apart because they're
spinning right but galaxies maintain
their structure and there when we look
at them all of the stars that are
shining don't create enough mass to
actually hold the galaxies together so
there has to be something else
contributing to the mass of those
galaxies that was the first indication
we had that there was something else
that we couldn't account for so there's
some form of mass that we couldn't
account for
now we haven't found what the source of
that mass is yet the most likely
candidate that we have or the one that
seems the most popular these things
called weakly interacting massive
particles which is a new kind of
particle the kind of things that
they look at in CERN their big particle
colliders they really really would love
to increase the energy of those particle
colliders to see if they can create some
dark matter particles
the trouble with dark matter is it
doesn't interact with our normal matter
through electromagnetism so through the
force of electromagnetism so that's how
we see things so the how we see anything
is because it's interacting with light
so they only interact through gravity
and gravity is such a weak force it
means that it's incredibly hard to
actually investigate that stuff
anyway so this is dark matter and that's
why that's so cool and there's more of
it than we thought yes cool crash
luenell and spill tardigrades on me oh
yeah so this was a unfortunate a failed
lunar mission which crashed on the moon
the Bereshit mission so there it was
trying to be a lunar lander and but it
crashed and so it released
tardigrades on the moon which we're
supposed to be there for an experiment
yeah and also released a late laser
etched copy of wikipedia well that's
cool so at least they got something to
read what's important for those of you
they don't know about tardigrades or
water bears is that we think that they
can probably survive like environments
as extreme as the moon's environment so
they might be living on the moon well
only in a sort of desiccated hibernation
state so they're not dead but they're
not alive and they're not doing anything
so it's not like I mean they're not
there are a lot of there of the asaurus
they're like a seed yeah yeah yeah
there's like a secret area yeah yeah
perfect analogy but they're not going to
move around and start multiplying and
yeah but anyway the interesting you have
to keep an eye on them and that's it
that's it for space next section next
section oh yeah sure
so there's a time delay which is why DOM
is going to give us music while you vote
on the next category oh and maybe we
should introduce ourselves yeah anyone
that's just joining in I'm Curtis Bodi I
run the YouTube channel Curtis belly
where I do science and environment
experiments and projects and this is
Dominic Waldman I do this channel domain
of science and I'm a human vote on what
category you would like to see next
we've covered physics genetics and space
there is still human evolution
artificial intelligence climate change
technology chemistry and medicine I'm
definitely not an alien I mean I've seen
a lot of climate change I've seen a lot
of climate change which is like my daily
life and chemistry okay let's do that
and also chemistry maybe okay across
this and I will get out how we do at the
time of case one an hour and an hour in
that's okay it's a marathon we've
covered some of our favorite topics so
maybe we'll go faster through the only
ones I don't know we'll see okay I got
to bring up climate change this was a
big year for climate change in a lot of
ways let's bring up the thing so you
guys can see what I'm actually talking
about no this one okay so this is a big
year for climate change both for the
planet and for the people on it I'm
going to start with the category oh yeah
the subtitle for my category of climate
change is the anthro procent or the and
through proceeding against a fussy
Anthropocene thank you which is like the
we're current scientists agree we're
currently in a mass extinction event
that's caused by humans it's gonna be a
dark category mostly
this is the way I see this obviously the
the motivation for this live stream is
to show all the positive results from
science this obviously is going to come
across
is very negative because just as what
good science is telling us is telling us
we are screwing up the climate but I
also see a positive side of this is that
this is really important information to
know and the better we can model the
climber and understand all the processes
the more we have the tools and the
weapons to fight the information war and
the political war yeah and there's also
some good points to know like some good
some good things happened in the science
of climate change which we'll talk I'll
talk about first thing the very start of
the year scientists announced that 2018
was the fourth warmest year on record in
recorded history for the entire planet
which is no huge surprise if you look at
the ten most like ten warmest years I
think almost all of them are in the last
15 years and 2019 though it's not quite
done yet is shaping up to be I think the
sixth warmest year ever it's been on the
planet is getting warmer
I'm gonna go quickly through a gonna do
kind of a lightning round of some of
these so climate change is being caused
by increased levels of carbon dioxide in
the atmosphere and in Hawaii which is
far away from everything else so they
can take a base level where is the
carbon dioxide at in our air and Hawaii
this year it crossed four hundred and
fifteen parts per million now that's a
big threshold that used to be around 360
originally right and we've caused it to
go that much higher which is the highest
level it's been in the last
two-and-a-half million years and at that
time two and half million years ago sea
levels were 20 meters higher than they
are now and the temperature of the
planet was three degrees warmer Celsius
so I mean that's like where we're headed
heads the direction things are going
good news in the climate crisis is that
scientists are finally starting to get a
little bit more political and actually
like stand together more on the issue so
they recently signed a 11,000 sign
tests set out like a political global
warming global warning that climate
change is happening and oh and the
second study from that is that someone
went through all of the research for the
first I think seven months yeah for the
first seven months of nineteen looked at
every peer-reviewed climate paper and
all of them agree that climate change is
happening but that's that's eleven
thousand six hundred papers so like it's
at least the very least now we've kind
of weaned out all of the bad science and
scientists can all back the fact that
climate change is happening and it's
because of us and that's good news
because it leaves no room for climate
denial so so that's good if you if you
get into a discussion with the climate
denier you can show them this article
cool that's the good news the bad news
is that it's melting the world is
melting so we're gonna go through these
kind of quickly because they are
repetitive but I think it's important to
to kind of give you a bit of the scope
Greenland ice is melting four times
faster than it was in 2003 that's a big
deal the another example of ice melting
the antic sorry the Arctic ice sheet is
melting at a rapid rate eleven billion
tons in one day which is the equivalent
of four point four million Olympic
swimming pools of ice melting into water
in a single day that never used to
happen that's like unfathomable which is
pretty wild yeah if if if it continues
to rise and melt this if the if the
Antarctic Ice Sheet continues to melt
this way then we'll expect to see a
multi meter sea level rise which is
pretty scary yeah we definitely want to
avoid yeah oh oh and then this is Sir
that was Arctic this is Antarctic also
losing losing a lot of mass so it was
losing six times
more ice mass annually than it was 40
years ago which is the the sort of
finding that we expected to happen when
we first discovered what climate change
is doing like in the in the 70s and 80s
because if the temperature of the globe
on average changes by one degree the
actual temperature fluctuations the
poles are a lot bigger and so these 1
degree temperatures are unfortunate
because it doesn't sound like such a big
deal
but actually in more extreme
environments is the swings are a lot
bigger which is causing a lot of these
yeah and we have like we had at least a
sort of equilibrium on the earth and the
extreme environments act as kind of a
buffer zone so we have all this ice that
normally stays there year-round and it
like absorb some of the fluctuations but
if it continues to melt then it won't be
there to sort of shield us against
climate change and it's melting
six times faster than it was 40 years
ago the other thing which is where this
gets even worse is that not only are
things melting but they're melting at a
rate that are faster than we expected
them to be so this report came out from
UN panel signals a red alert on the blue
planet basically this came out that it
was revised projection of the sea level
rise we thought it was going to be it's
basically sea level rise we think will
be 10 centimeters higher by the end of
the century that we thought it would be
which is a significant like that's
that's this much of a difference which
since most of most people on the earth
well a lot of people live next to the
sea that's gonna affect people directly
I think we're gonna we're seeing a lot
of these sorts of studies come through
that are like it's worse than we thought
because scientists are pretty inherently
conservative in how they produce the
results right if you to get through the
process of peer review it's easier to
paper survived more easily by not making
super super bold claims right and I
think we're seeing a lot of those older
studies be revised to be like
actually it's worse than you were saying
yeah 300 million people displaced would
be yeah the biggest refugee crisis yeah
and so this is again this is triple what
the previous estimate was so and that's
just in terms of flooding that's in
terms of people being displaced because
of flooding not because the place is too
hot or because there's there's no water
for them that's just flooding speaking
of water a third of the Himalayan ice
caps are doomed which is a big deal
because that is the water supply for
about two billion people on the earth I
mean the most are populate the densest
populated parts of the planet is around
the Himalayas so that's what we the big
deal moving on a little bit from from
climate change specifically to the earth
problem more broadly is that plastic
pollution which I've done a lot of
videos on because it's a big deal it's
not just affecting fish but we get
there's there's millions of tons of
plastic thrown out into the oceans every
year but it's not just affecting the the
fish life and there it's also harming
the bacteria that help us breathe so
it's harming the bacteria that make
oxygen and that's a big deal
that could have like a cascade impact
that we don't really fully understand
yet the that awk that bacteria is
responsible for 10 percent of the oxygen
that we breathe that humans breathe and
plastic is affecting it so whoa that's
the like that's this is the last last
one
the conclusion is basically that this is
the Anthropocene this is a human caused
extinction event and it's worse than we
thought it was what that means is that
well I have it here biodiversity loss is
accelerating with over a million species
now threatened with extinction it's a
happening at an unprecedented rate and
yeah it's something that I think we all
need to do a lot more about
not just in terms of like your daily
life I mean it's great if you can like
reduce your impact personally like drive
less fly less buy last eat less read me
yeah that's all good but we also it's
like way past time that would make some
really big significant government
changes and like we need to we need to
crack down on on this big like we need
to stop taking fuel out of the ground
basically is there anyone so sometimes
when I'm faced with all of this news I
start feeling a bit helpless because you
look at the amount of waste going on in
large-scale industry and in cities and
you like well I can do my bit so is
there any way that we as an individual
can actually change like leverage our
votes from like what's the best way that
we can do things after we say we've just
set our bait our own personal base and
to be so I think the two most important
things you can well 3 most important
things you can do are first you need to
know though I mean this is like a three
minute five minute overview you need to
like everybody should be reading books
and doing research watching videos like
learning as much about the climate as
they can I think that once you do that
you're very empowered because you
realize that like you're your very
existence is at threat so once you've
done that you can vote obviously support
climate like climate people that are
really hoping to make big changes in
terms of what politicians have actual
green policies that work and also you
can go in and be an activist you can
protest there's lots of things you can
do if you just like type in climate
change activism in your city and
Facebook for example you'll find places
and people that can that you can join in
but we need to we need to like really
step up our game that's it for clinic
target hopefully 2020 will be the big
change here in terms of active action
but let's cross our fingers livestream
has hit 100 likes so that's some
positive news the only category I think
that is really really dark yeah yeah
yeah rest of the the rest of the year's
summary should be pretty happy ok so we
have still human evolution artificial
intelligence technology chemistry and
medicine so please place your votes now
this guitars lovely guitar is a lair of
a guitar we're not sponsored by them or
anything but this is the same makeup
guitar that's on the International Space
Station I don't remember if you don't
know if you remember seeing Chris
Hadfield it's Space Oddity yeah because
he's Canadian Canadian guitar they're
actually made we're both in Vancouver in
Canada right now and actually meet these
guitars right here and they're very
lovely guitars so you might have the
same model of guitar that is all
International Space Station it's really
cool I've seen like a lot of votes for
chemistry I feel like it's a pretty
clear win ok chemistry chemistry that
was Dom's topic okay I'll get it up
[Music]
I find chemistry fascinating because I
only know tangentially what I know from
what I've learned from physics are know
kind of the fundamentals in terms of the
periodic table and stuff like that some
of this stuff in chemistry is amazing so
this is like a perfect way to follow the
climate change news because a lot of
this is the kind of stuff that we can do
which will help fight against climate
change from a technological point of
view so groundbreaking new technique can
turn plastic waste into energy dense
fuels so in terms of plastic pollution
is so much of our plastic unfortunately
ends up in the oceans this is a new
technique where you can actually take
that plastic waste and turn it into
a useful hydrocarbon fuel it's still a
hydrocarbon fuel so it's still a fossil
fuel but it's at least a way of making
something that's useful out of our
plastic waste which is very cool I think
this is the same one okay yeah science
turn come dogs are back into coal so
this was a cool story because currently
when we do carbon capture we store it in
liquids and liquids hard to store and
they take up volume and they can leak in
two different places or gas you can pump
the carbon dioxide gas into into the
ground and store it underground but
there's always the potential that it
leaks out storing it into coal as a
solid is a much better solution for that
because it's in a it's gonna stay there
where it's not completely inert properly
but it's gonna stay for a lot longer and
be a lot stable than so if you put a
load of coal back into the ground that's
going to be a much better way of storing
it to date carbon has only been
converted into a solid solid at very
high temperatures whereas this is a new
technique that doesn't involve high
temperatures so creating high
temperatures to convert the co2 into
coal obviously burns a lot of energy -
which is kinda productive so this is a
fantastic new way of doing carbon
capture yeah which is amazing it needs
to be either very energy efficient or
fueled by oil it needs to be both energy
efficient and fuelled by renewable
energy but like that would be awesome
that we could turn back the clock
interest on because I remember reading
this I think this one you can do it
through renewable energies yes it should
be able to Oh
[Music]
this was using
okay yeah I remember this so this was
using liquid metals as a catalyst as
possible to turn the gas back into
carbon at room temperature that's cool
and it's efficient and scalable too so
yeah this could be great another one
Dave okay it's hard to study chemical
reactions directly because they happen
so quickly that it's impossible to know
exactly what's going on but there's a
new technique where you can actually see
imaged the actual chemical reaction
that's cool which is very cool
okay is it interesting yeah so radical
desalination approach may disrupt the
water industry water becomes more scarce
this is a potentially good and this is
you and this is specifically about
hypersaline
liquid so that's when does the the
amount of salts that's dissolved into
the water is you know six ten times six
to ten times more than in in normal
seawater and this happens a lot from
industrial processes and yeah there's a
list in in the article of the processes
that produce these hopes a membranes and
currently what you'd have to do is keep
those isolated and separate from your
water supply because if they leak into
the woods where they can contaminate
that and also to deal with them
currently the best way is to either do
diffusion using a membrane is it called
diffusion I think it's a few but it's
basically having a gradient over a
membrane and though those become harder
and how does this do as because you need
a pressure on the membrane and the more
saturated the water is the how the salt
content is the harder is to you
use a membrane to get rid of to get
clean water out and the other way to do
it is actually to evaporate the water to
just leave the soul at the end which is
obviously energy intensive - or it takes
a very long time you rely on sunlight
this is a different technique that
doesn't need either of those it's
according to this low-cost and efficient
core temperature swing solvent
extraction so there's more information
in that article for those who've just
joined we're going to actually link to
this a couple of documents with all of
these information so you can go and see
all the original articles at the end of
the video ok next one is energy
researchers break the catalytic speed
limit this is the to me sounds insane
because they've made reactions occur up
to a thousand times faster than they
would ten thousand to ten thousand times
ten thousand fold increase in the speed
of reactions when using a catalyst so
catalysts are basically you have two
chemicals you want to react with each
other they'll happen at a certain rate
but you can have a catalyst that
actually helps the reaction air it's
like an intermediate step
they're like cheerleaders you don't play
the game but they help the game
yeah and so normally this is like it you
can have a solution of two chemicals
that are going to react and then you put
in some metal into that solution and
that makes the reaction happen faster
but they've discovered that if you
actually vibrate that piece of metal so
you like ultrasonic frequencies you can
increase the rate of those reactions by
ten thousand times which sounds like it
would be incredibly useful in the
article I was saying the amount of
different processes we use catalyst for
is just a massive long list and if you
can increase the time
yeah make them all more efficient make
all sorts of drugs and all sorts of
things more affordable mmm
Kevin Smith first ever ring of pure
carbon so this is in the realm of carbon
nanotubes and graphene this is another
type of carbon that they've managed to
make being which is useful for making
small-scale electronics in the future
who think all now this is the I think
the coolest story it's a way to make
cement but without causing any emissions
and this is a big deal because eight
percent of the carbon emissions on our
world are because we're making cement to
build buildings can roads and all sorts
of things yeah and so this new technique
is very cool because it eliminates the
the normal method that you would extract
the bits of cement so which is normally
used by heating up limestone so when you
heat up limestone you need to burn
fossil fuels to eat it up and then also
you need to know the actual limestone as
it burns it releases carbon - it's about
50% from each of those processes this is
a technique which uses electricity to
create cement and if you get the
electricity from a renewable energy
source you can actually create cement
with without any source of greenhouse
gases the only emission is actually
oxygen and hydrogen which potentially
you can combine to get energy out of it
and the only emission is water vapor so
this is very cool it's not yet been
scaled up so scaling it up for global
cement production is gonna take time and
it's not a thing currently that you can
just roll out so they're saying that the
best ways to do this is it's a
multi-step process and so maybe you can
replace one part of the cement
production with one part of this and
then do it as a staggered approach but
this is a
big deal because I mean we have all
sorts of renewable energy options we're
starting to figure out transportation
like electric cars and even electric
planes but cement is still has been like
the big like we don't know what we're
gonna do like how are we gonna what are
we gonna use for roads this is cool very
cool so if that's the end of the
chemistry section but if advances like
this keep on happening we can we can
attack climate change from the
technological point of view we can true
I think it's dangerous to rely on that
because that's what a lot of very
optimistic technologists say is that we
can just innovate our way out of this
catastrophe
I don't think 100% we shouldn't be
relying on that we need to do the
political movements to but but now we
have options yeah which is an important
step cool okay so next category we're
looking at we have human evolution
technology and medicine or missed
artificial intelligence human evolution
is like all of biology but it's mostly
human evolution yeah that's true love
this live stream thank you we got a
couple for Evo I think it's all Evo and
oxygenation which is in a category I
don't know why I missed something in the
threat with that and someone's voting
nothing very helpful I think and I'm
seeing AI overall I see more for human
okay let's do which I'm happy to to do
okay okay bring this up so I have my
notes okay we ready to start this is a
very so a lot of these studies didn't
actually even make oh this is the wrong
one and you see this one first a lot of
these studies didn't make big news but
they're really fascinating they might
have obscure titles so that's a warning
for this section Japanese team I just
closer to bringing mammoths back to life
so there's this a bunch of research
being done 2d extinct animals like the
passenger pigeon because we have all of
their DNA and we have similar animals
that we could use to birth those
creatures so basically the idea for this
is that you take mammoth DNA which we
find from like old men tusks which is
cool and we can use that DNA and put it
into an embryo and put that into an
elephant and create a woolly mammoth for
the first time in like ten thousand
twenty eight thousand years they've been
extinct for a very very long time so
this is neat there's all sorts of
questions about like should we be doing
this what would be the point but like by
the way it's it's interesting science
yeah yeah not sure how I feel about
making yeah the ethical side of things
the woolly mammoth I mean it would be
cool but what would we do with it we
would just have it in a zoo and make
money from it we might yeah I think this
isn't it gets really tricky to answer
that sort of question when you think
about like why did woolly mammoths go
extinct in the first place it was
probably largely from humans like we
hunted them and that's gonna be the case
for like the passenger pigeon we we
caused that to go extinct we killed them
so it may be for those for some of those
things like it would be good to like
take it back what stay back I can see a
use case in in environments when we've
ruined like a keystone species of an
environment and now it's extinct
reintroducing that makes a lot of sense
yeah woolly mammoth it's been extinct
for such a long time an actual but
anyway no sub derail things so this is a
complicated title but what's really cool
about this study is that researchers
basically looked at the DNA of humans
and figured out that there was some
other there was code there from
something else that was probably another
type of human
so like there is probably based on this
based on this based on this like kind of
genetic modeling they figured out that
there's an extinct species of human not
Homo Sapien but us a relative just from
DNA within us we fact we found that that
existed at one point that's really cool
very cool yeah so if we don't have
fossils of them but we know that they
existed so it's not a Neanderthal it's
not a D Imman and hybrid yeah yeah it's
it's something completely different
which is really cool
also we notice that because just like
Neanderthal we bred with them like
aren't great ancestors we're making
babies with them and some of their DNA
lingered in us which is neat it's kind
of like to give a an analogy it's like
searching for planet 9 we don't we've
not seen planet 9 but we can figure out
that it probably exists because of the
way that gravity pulls things in there
in the orbits of planets very cool we
can see it in DNA that's really neat I
think that's like the first time that's
happened when with humans okay so going
further back to the aggregate all our
ancient relatives what was this paper
about oh yeah we found out a bunch of
things about Neanderthal so we looked at
the isotopes of carbon and nitrogen
which basically allow us to gauge what
was happening at the time those
individuals were alive based on
complicated chemistry we figured out
that they probably ate meat which is
something that we didn't know for sure
because meat doesn't really keep in
terms of it doesn't really fossilized
very well and they also probably walked
upright much like modern humans so we
learned a lot about Neanderthal which in
any we've discovered fossils with a very
large bird it is what is it called a
giant parrot named the Hercules parrot
which is pretty cool it was almost a
meter tall it was it was yeah it was one
meter tall which is a giant bird that's
a little kind of neat
they also discovered the fossil remnants
of what is it called a fossilized fungus
so this is going further and further
back way be at wave of more humans some
of the earliest things to land to go on
land as life were probably fungus that
paved the way for plants and fungi don't
fossilize very well so it's very very
rare for us to see fossils of them but
this is this is really neat this is a
billion year old fossil of a mushroom
essentially which is really neat and
then I got a very bad up they also going
way back to basically the beginning of
complex life they've discovered this
very large Medusa virus or a relative of
it that was probably responsible for the
very first complicated your eukaryotic
cells so basically what they think
happened is some simple prokaryotic
cells how to begin that's like like
bacteria combined to make these
eukaryotic cells but we have the plants
have the fungi have so as we really
really need then basically discovering
the very start of life with this project
there's a giant virus best interest yeah
that is like all of us yeah I know you
start yeah that's very very beginning of
it category next cope so we've got
artificial intelligence technology in
medicine left so at the live stream yeah
oh dear I saw a lots of folks for I've
seen a lot of it yeah I so let's see do
young fungi microbial yeah I don't think
they taste good anymore than me rock now
any votes I mean we could rely on the
earlier vote yeah AI lots of the I vote
so it's okay okay cool
okay I'll bring up my notes so a in the
world of AI artificial intelligence in
2019 there's a big year for yes I mean
every since 2010 pretty much every
single year is a big year for AI because
it's expanding and getting more and more
elaborate every single year we're really
in a sort of golden age of AI currently
so a lot of these news stories revolve
around AI playing games - this one is
deep mind Google's or alphabets company
they learn how to play Starcraft 2 so
well that they beat professional players
they think in eleven out in ten out of
eleven games which is as someone who's
like tried to play Starcraft it's hard
and then watching people play it online
like the professionals it's like I don't
even know the human body can click that
fast
yeah MC and it's hard and this is a big
step up from being like Atari games and
stuff like that because you're playing
against a human opponent and you're also
playing with imperfect knowledge because
a lot of the other games you have all
the perfect knowledge of what the game
is doing but because a lot of I've never
actually played Starcraft but from what
I understand is there's hidden areas of
the map to begin with it's all hidden
and you have to send scouts out to get
information to know what your opponents
are doing and where they're doing those
and so this is in terms of games is a
very complicated game step up from go
and chess and the other things that they
do so this is very cool thing you've
already covered this this is finding a
ghost ancestor in the human genome so
yeah we've covered this already yeah
some of these topics use multiple fields
of science yeah when we talk about like
chemists this is just chemistry it's
like well I mean science is very
collaborative you so this is cool using
on genetics actually discover creatures
in our in our genome like I think it's
fascinating just to tie a few threads
together early on we were talking about
how DNA is a data storage device and
this is now doing information science
and machine learning on that information
source if we had some kind of like
ultimate knowledge of how DNA ends up in
coding creatures it would be an insanely
powerful thing to do because we could we
could retrace all of evil ooh from the
history just by looking at the DNA of
the animals that exist now and see
basically all of the intermediary
animals that probably existed and that's
a kind of the goal I guess it is to just
fundamentally understand how DNA turns
into creatures what's super wild is that
it was in the 60s that we even
discovered DNA like 60 years ago and now
we're like oh this species existed
because of how well we can read and
understand DNA that's incredible
brilliant
okay this was in other games so this is
Carnegie Mellon University beating top
professional Texas Hold'em poker players
people who won millions of dollars
playing poker again you're working with
imperfect information imperfect
information and also playing against six
opponents at a time which is more
difficult than just doing one opponent
to get it and again broadly like you're
like how why do I care that AI can play
games well it's like if you can solve
these sorts of problems we can also use
it to solve important problems but this
is like a really easy way to test black
way to test that out gay games are a
nice test case for AI because they have
solid rules
so the world in which they sold the
problem is constrained so when you're
trying to build something like a
self-driving car you're dealing with the
actual real world and complexity of the
wheel
real world is basically endless whereas
with games you know that there's a
certain limit to the rules that you're
trying to beat so that's why a lot of
these early results are in specifically
games because that's something that we
can encode better for a computer but one
of the things that we find fascinating
them as humans about games is because
they're complicated systems that we're
not actually very good at solving so
computers in a way of more like they can
do more stuff when it comes to
enumerated all the different
possibilities of poker hands they can
just know all of the probabilities off
the top of a head which is already an
advantage if you could do that as a
human that would give you an advantage
the other thing that's really
interesting about these things when when
alphago beat the best go player in the
world it did things that go players were
really surprised at and so it had
actually created new strategies that no
human had ever thought of and the same
thing happened in poker they were
surprised at some of the decisions that
this AI chose to do to beat the humans
also another thing about playing poker
is that you want to not be predictable
and so you want to have a certain amount
of randomness to the strategies that you
play and is easier for a computer to do
that the alternate poker face
so that's cool an Atari game so this is
RMIT University have performed they've
completed Montezuma's Revenge ten times
faster than Google this is apparently a
very difficult game yeah we have a
robotic hand can solve a Rubik's Cube so
this is not only well I guess solving
Rubik's cubes is fairly easy from a
computational point of view but the
manipulation of an object like a Rubik's
Cube in a hand is really hard so
robotics style human style and so this
is machine learning as it applies to
medicine
so using image recognition
AI can detect when six skin conditions
as accurately as dermatologists can so
cool which is very cool if we can
automate things like detection of skin
conditions that would be huge yeah I
mean we already like go straight to I go
straight to Google I've been sick the
last few days and I go straight to
Google to be like what is this it'll be
so cool if I could like what are my
tonsils doing they take a photo and
google tells me that's me yeah so this
is I think in general and a really
really interesting area is applying
machine learning to medicine and they're
actually testing it against the the key
thing is to test it against the experts
and see how well these these machines do
so okay so this is they've identified a
is AI based drug discovery platform has
identified a target and drug candidate
for Wilson's disease so this is
[Music]
basically trying to look through how
drugs interact with the body and you can
apply machine learning to drug discovery
as well and so this is a result in that
very cool yeah okay so oh this is not
supposed to be here this is something
about interference in quantum we've
already done physics oh that's fine okay
okay the final two categories donar I
forgot to scrub off artificial
intelligence yeah we can do that so it's
now between medicine and Technology cast
your votes in the comment section please
there's gonna be obviously again overlap
between these last two because we've
talked about a lot of D like medicine
and genetic into engineering things but
technology crosses over quite a lot with
AI and physics as well
when they'll protect two votes for tech
three votes for okay we're going with
Tech's are a technology loan and
medicine maniac we'll get to your
medicine next okay all right
oh yeah you doing okay we've got three
computers so I'm like grabbing the wrong
letters oh okay
so lots of 3d printing results
so just rapid fire some of these so our
technology I've got a list
so it'll says 3d printing the human
heart that could be cool so yeah 3d
printing organs
is good so research the University of
Michigan demonstrates a new approach to
3d printing based on lifting shapes from
a vat of liquid so it's a new way of
extruding oops extruding objects outside
of it out of a liquid is a hundred times
faster than previous processes so speed
ups in 3d printing there's this story
which is 3d printing bio printing tissue
scaffolds made from collagen so this is
cool for potentially building
replacement organs using your own stem
cells using your own cells so they won't
get rejected by your body and also you
don't have to do the crazy Pig making
yeah doing the pig thing which is good
if you can avoid you know there's also a
new type of 3d printing that can print
an object the size of a human in two
hours that's wild so you can print much
bigger objects than you used to be able
to read and Jesse as a 3d printer and
it's like really fascinating but god
they're so slow yeah it's like yeah I'll
do two days later I'll come back there's
also a rinse
mayor polytechnic institute they just
demonstrated way to 3d print living skin
including blood vessels which could be
used for more accurate skin grafts which
just sounds wild really very very cool
so lots of advances in 3d printing
that's there in technology the first one
terabyte SD card was built as someone
that uses a lot of SD cards to make
videos that'd be an insane in my fifties
this is very cool so there's a passive
way of cooling buildings which is this
box here which basically doesn't need
any electricity or batteries or anything
and it can cool certain areas of a
building down by 11 degrees Celsius I
think just very small areas but what it
does is it beams the energy into space
which is the whole thing so what it does
is we can't make this up and it the the
absorbs heat from the air around it so
the air in this cavity the energy from
that is transferred into these veins and
then the veins emit the infrared
radiation into space wavelength where it
doesn't then get reabsorbed by the
atmosphere as that couples oh that is so
cool so yeah passive cooling is amazing
air conditioning systems in hotter areas
use a loss of energy this is great
because the planet is getting warmer
when people are currently like using
more air conditioning to keep their
houses cooler we are using more fuel so
this is awesome mostly that was my mind
space yeah that's very cool with 3d
printing at the nano scale so a thousand
times faster printing at the nano scale
which is very cool oh yeah this is
Google's results of quantum supremacy
you probably heard this earlier in the
year for those of you who haven't heard
this so quantum computers are computers
that
use the laws of quantum mechanics to
solve problems so that's basically very
very small things that use superposition
entanglement it allows you to compute in
a different way to normal computers so
they can solve certain problems a lot
faster or to got that they've got the
potential to solve certain problems a
lot faster than the binary classical
computers we use so a bunch of companies
around the world in a race to make
quantum computers that are scale where
you can actually solve real world
problems they're not there yet but this
is one benchmark on the way there which
is this so-called quantum supremacy I've
done some videos on my channel about
quantum computing and quantum one on
quantum supremacy specifically and what
this is is basically demonstrating that
this quantum puter can solve one problem
faster than any classical computer can
in faster than the most powerful
supercomputer and so Google demonstrated
this on a problem which is not a useful
problem so it's not actually solving a
useful problem but just being able to
solve any kind of problem faster than a
classical computer is a good result the
the results got disputed by IBM who have
the world's fastest supercomputer so the
reasoning made sense and there I don't
think they've published yet but they're
gonna publish a paper which is a
challenge to this paper and honestly I'm
not surprised the wall between quantum
computing and classical computing is
going to be this stepwise race where one
shows a result in quantum computing and
then they'll innovate in terms of
classical computing to come up with some
clever techniques total computers are so
insanely adaptable you can engineer them
to all sorts of things and I kind of in
my old job when I was working on quantum
computing I kind of experienced some of
these exact stuff but first hand anyway
is a very very cool result and the
advances in quantum computing a
meeting the the potential computing for
specifically solving simulating quantum
systems I think is really exciting so
this is in terms of chemistry drug
discovery finding new materials
currently our computers not powerful
enough to simulate lots of atoms all
interacting with each other we even in
the biggest supercomputers we can only
simulate small systems of atoms in the
future if we have large-scale quantum
computers they're literally a simulation
of of atoms interacting with each other
and so if we can run simulations at a
large scale that would be a huge
technology it's like a computing of
fundamental of materials our engineers
develop a new way to remove carbon
dioxide from the air so this I put in
the technology and sort of the into sort
of the chemistry area the reason this is
cool is because it can remove carbon
dioxide from the air any concentration
level traditional techniques want a high
concentration of carbon to be the most
efficient and it uses this is the one
that uses batteries yes so this is
basically it uses the carbon in the air
to charge up a battery so it's like the
thing that charges up the battery
instead of electrons it's actually
carbon and then you have carbon
sequestered from the air yes good and
they look like a double whammy yeah
double whammy and if you want you can
release the carbon again to release the
electricity and then maybe capture the
carbon in some other way I don't know
that's cool so that's very cool a more
efficient solar cells through nano
technology so converting infrared light
into energy more efficiently than before
there's a number to this 10% so
increasing the efficiency to 10% and
perhaps up to 20 to 25% more efficient
solar cells and it makes you can see
this array of lenses that actually focus
the light which is how that works this
next ones
while sells sorry yeah so good to the
excited Google of built a factory to
build self-driving cars is in Michigan
which I didn't know it's finally
happening
yeah it's not driving cars I'm a bit of
a self-driving car skeptic yeah because
I feel like the problem they're trying
to solve is so difficult that the things
we're talking about I think in
mainstream consciousness and how the
news has talked about self-driving cars
I'm a little bit surprised that people
think it's so close I don't think it's
as close as what people are claiming so
this I mean a lot of people are saying
within the next two three four or five
years or something like that but I think
it's going to be further off than that
for the very reasons I was stating
earlier that the world is incredibly
complicated and these self-driving cars
if you want to be able to sit back and
just not be attentive at the steering
wheel it just completely controls itself
I just don't see that is yes so the hard
part seem the harder parts for assault
driving cars seemed to be like in
inner-city short distance travel right
yeah because there's like a lot of
information for it to take in and
there's a lot of people and pedestrian
yeah and so on but the like most of the
accidents for drivers and passengers are
on the highway which like in
self-driving technology has gotten
pretty good yeah so highway driving is
the easiest which is great the most
you're a traveling at like hundreds of
kilometers an hour yeah yeah yeah so
that's true that's true so it's I'm
excited yeah okay that's good I mean I'm
excited to but I'm just trying to be
realistic I don't want to I would
absolutely love there to be self-driving
cars today coming Tomatoes and then this
one is slightly silly but also very cool
the world's largest computer chip which
is like this big or something so you
know your CPU is normally about an inch
in the middle of your computer now you
could have a CPU that's a massive slab
is that good do we want them bigger
I guess there's like more I guess you've
just got more computing
power in in that one chip I think the
problem would be that it would heat up
so much because that's that I think one
of the limits anyway cool technology so
if you're gonna let you vote on the next
category no because there's only one
left
actually let's let you vote anyone
anyone want to vote for medicine all the
secret wildcard actually rambling about
a balloon we do actually have a secret
one oh yeah we do we do have C but we're
not we're gonna do okay
Oh medicine is mine I should do the
things okay go back big year for
medicine again some overlap with DNA
executive files okay some overlap with
genetics because now we're using that in
medicine which is neat so there was a
big really cool case of unfortunate
circumstance turned good this teenager
had a lung transplant was it let's see I
think it was a lung transplant gotta go
up to the top of my notes getting lots
of votes for medicine yes good schools
so this teenager had a lung transplant
which to begin with is amazing but then
they had a deadly infection not good and
then we had a thing called genetic
genetically modified phage therapy which
a phage is like a virus that looks like
the virus it looks if you've seen the
matrix and that thing that goes into
Neos bellybutton page viruses look like
that but we were able to use them to
create
druggers it's like a drug resistant
technology all of our drugs all of
bacteria and the viruses that that we
use drugs on are getting resistant to
those drugs we might have a completely
new way of affecting those so that's
awesome she's 17 and seems to be doing
well which is cool that's pretty cool
end to AIDS so this is a
a really cool large study of 1,000 gay
male couples who took this
antiretroviral therapy and this is like
a big study that's been happening over
the last eight years and with this this
antiretroviral therapy is basically a
number of like a concoction of different
things that are bad for the virus and
when you take all of these in concert
what they found is that the virus does
not transfer transfer from one partner
to the other which is awesome because if
we use this like effectively we could
eradicate it yeah that's cool which is
like really exciting that's a huge news
so that's cool they found that yeah
there were no further infections which
is which is like the best news possible
this is all the articles about this
we're like really weird because they
were like dinosaur metal it was like a
diet it was the metal from an asteroid I
want to listen to dinosaur nests well I
think that sounds like good music yeah
if some of these things is like well how
do we talk about them but there's this
obscure metal that they can so it's
iridium attached to albumin mm-hmm I'm
not sure if I can oh it's pronounced but
anyway they basically put it into cancer
cells and then they can shine light on
it and that irradiation can destroy
those cancer cells what's cool is that
they can basically give people this this
metal as a drug it will go into the
cancer cells and will get up taken by
them and then they just shine light on
it and it kills them because the metals
heat up I think oh it's from
photodynamic therapy I don't know
exactly what that means but very really
really the process for so this section I
is like the aging and cancer section
gene therapy
reverses congenital deafness and mice
okay right so this article a lot of
these a lot of the studies in medicine
Kanno are done in medicine but earths
are done in mice but may be applicable
for humans we don't really have that
many ways of restoring like hearing at
all but this is genetically deaf mice
but they've been able to basically turn
that gene back on and allow them to hear
again which is really really neat
hopefully that will be available in
humans at some point another gene
therapy example this woman was the first
person to have the aging blindness
halted thus very cool really really neat
so it's age-related macular degeneration
what they did is they injected a virus
into her retinal cells and that virus
held the DNA that that was injected
through the virus into her cells that
basically stopped them from producing
the stuff that was causing her blindness
yeah amazing
that's amazing it didn't it didn't like
reverse as far as I could tell it didn't
reverse her blindness but it stopped it
from progressing so in theory when if
you catch it early you could prevent it
entirely which is really really neat
this is like this study to me was like
really fascinating and super exciting
Alzheimer's is where you have a
complaint really extreme memory loss and
it effects I think I maybe wrote it down
it affects like millions of people a
huge percentage of the population and as
you get older it's it's high it's a high
probability disease they basically
researchers gave this gave participants
this headset that pushed that put
electromagnetic waves that affected
basically it's kind of like a plaque
that develops on your neurons and it
basically like vibrates them and
destroys them
and it was able to reverse the effects
of Alzheimer's in the people that use
this just for two times a day for an
hour like really simple you can just
like wear it and walk around normally
but it reversed the effects of
Alzheimer's for what like the equivalent
of a year of degeneration so it was like
they got their life back to a year
earlier just a sense almost too good to
be true that's a really really neat so
no drugs or anything just put on this
headset yeah the UH the interview from
the researcher that did this was so like
heartwarming it was like you know we get
like data and it shows that these things
are working love the thing the thing
that really drove it home to me is that
out of all the participants we gave the
headset to none of them wanted to give
it back at the end of the experiment and
someone even said a patient said I've
come back let's just like wow you know
like that's just fascinating and so
excited anyway very good so I hope
there's hope for hope for that again
this is a topic that yeah yeah yeah but
uh huge advancements in medicine through
3d printing oh yeah this is also really
like this is future medicine
nanotechnology made it possible for mice
to see infrared which is like right okay
so what they've basically done is put in
this what was it called a nanoparticle
some sort of I think it was maybe even a
metal but what it did I could be wrong
about but what it did was refracted the
light they injected this little thing
into these mices eyes and it bent the
wavelengths of light so that infrared
which is a large wavelength I think
right down sorry infrared is a longer
way yeah it's a longer wavelength
invisible way and it basically bent it
to be a shorter wavelength so that the
mice could see it that's cool so that's
really neat and the effect lasted up to
ten weeks which was really cool would be
really wild if we could like have like
temporary see different wavelengths of
light we need to add to the increased
brain capacity
from the eight based DNA yeah exactly
cool that's it for medicine a lot of
other in my studies we'll see where
those go in the next few years but very
exciting scene that's it we've got to
the end of our list we've checked them
all off thanks everyone for being on the
stream we just like to finish with our
pick of the best stories of the decade
as we're getting to the end of the what
do we call them I've gone through this
whole decade without actually knowing
what to call 2010 to 2010 the tweens
they're 20 times okay yeah there's a lot
of things that happened I was just blown
away this morning thinking about this
the Curiosity rover landed in 2012 that
was this yes yes longer code there's a
lot that's happen so in there in the
stream how about you give us what you
think your best what the best science
stories of the last decade are shower
and we'll try and do a list at the end
we'll we'll just do a few of our picks
so Curiosity rover was one massive one
another one was the detection of
gravitational way you should have been
very first time that is 20 recently yeah
2015 was when it was done but it was
published in 2016 but that's amazing a
whole new mechanism that we can look
into space and so that's gonna be it's
already been astounding what we've
discovered we found thousands of
exoplanets planets not in our system but
elsewhere like Kepler space this is the
one we're literally more of them come
out every day so I don't know what the
current count is but last time I checked
there was like four and a half thousand
planets including Kepler 22b which looks
to be pretty similar to earth which is
cool discover the Higgs boson oh yeah so
that happened this decade which is
amazing the God our God well yeah but
yeah that completes the standard model
of particle physics we find the Higgs
boson which is amazing came up with
CRISPR cast iron which is like already
as you saw everything
and genetics like that's a new
technology as of this decade and we're
already using that to solve all sorts of
human elements which is pretty neat Levi
says Higgs particle good one yeah black
hole discovery was the favorite Higgs
boson couple the Higgs boson quantum
computing LIGO graphene the a graphene a
lot of stuffs been happening in graphene
which is cool quantum computing is cool
so that's been going on since well the
9th is actually but in the last decade
it's actually hit its stride and now at
the ferb for the first time at scale
quantum computers are being made found
water in the solar system not just on
Mars which we talked about from 2019 but
also we found it on the moon and in
Europa Europa one I think will Mars and
Europa is really cool they like with
Mars they saw an asteroid hit Mars and
like looked at the plume and saw like
basically steam rising which is really
really even one thing I was really
excited about from this decade because I
love the environment but I also really
love space and like space travel and
those two things often kind of compete
we came up with renewable sort of
reusable rockets like SpaceX and a
couple other companies launch rockets
that you had land that's mind-blowing oh
that's so cool yeah we've got we we've
got a age reversal on the feed yeah my
such oh in mice so we've come along and
like there's a lot of studies that's not
aware of that that's it there's yeah
there's a number of studies so it's hard
to like really define when that happened
but there's been a lot of progress in
that so we'll see what happens in humans
in the next decade what was the AI in
general yeah that's another one AI has
come up such a long way this AI boom
kind of started around 2008 2009 and so
yeah it's been the decade of AI
basically which is very cool voyager
left the solar system several times i
mean that and that like we kept the
space probe that we launched in 1977 as
it like passed all of the planets and
then passed but
or planets and then the Oort cloud we
just kept thinking like oh that's the
end of the solar system but it just kept
going and finding more stuff but at some
point it definitely left the solar
system which is cool Carty says ooh mom
I left the chat yeah that's good yeah
that was a discovery pop this like weird
space item popped in and out of our
solar system really really quickly and
weirdly Axl
Soderberg says new state of matter in
space I don't know they didn't know
about
would you like care to elaborate uh-huh
um we have a world's first malaria
vaccine program the game began this year
that's cool but like that's uh that
vaccine has been developed over the last
decade really really cool they it's coin
someone says big coin I think that
starts in 2007 but it's exploded over
this decade and I kind of wish I had
bought some in 2007 I tried to no way
story but I would have had a lot of
money from that but it's okay anyway a
lot a new tool new to us yeah science
discovery I mean that's like a decade
it's been really cool and it's been
super exciting and I'm looking forward
to seeing what happens in the next ten
years
yeah so thanks for joining us on this
long livestream it's been over two hours
and so us so we probably need to shut up
and go but thanks for sticking with us I
hope you've enjoyed that would you I
guess this is the time where we plug
things so Curtis please would you go and
plug two things one if you want to go
check out the videos that I make over on
my channel it is just Curtis and Bodi if
you search guy seals himself in a jar
you'll probably find it the other thing
is we and maybe I'm stealing this from
you we use Wikipedia to find like all of
this like that's where all this started
so and Wikipedia is based like run from
donations so if you want to help support
Wikipedia make things like this possible
go and donate to Wikipedia just go to
Mecca pedia and
click the donate button yeah I would
just want to like reiterate that
Wikipedia I think is something that a
lot of us take for granted that it
exists but it doesn't it wouldn't need
to exist it was just the fact that when
Jimmy Wales started he decided I'm not
going to try and monetize this through
advertising and we know from Google and
we know from Facebook and all the rest
of social media how creepy targeted that
and even YouTube to which were on here
so slightly hypocritical but all of this
stuff the machine learning about
targeted advertising is really creepy
so donating to Wikipedia that's how they
rely on keeping it free for anyone to
use and anyone into the world I believe
very strongly about access to education
which is my motivation for doing YouTube
because I want to have create
educational resources that can be freely
access and Wikipedia is like the most
amazing version of that so I would
really encourage everyone here if you've
got a bit of spare cash to go to
Wikipedia and donate to them whatever
you can afford I put a really messy link
in the chat but we'll leave another one
in the DAO we'll put one in the
description too so if you're watching
this at a later date go do that and as
for playing my stuff I mean check out my
channel do all the normal stuff we
always say subscribe and all that I also
sell merchandise so this is a lovely
quantum mechanics inspired mug I also
sell lots of posters on dftba so just so
domain of science on dftba I want to
find stuff we also both have patreon too
so anyway this has been a lot of fun
yeah I hope you enjoyed it thank you
yeah thank you okay so I place our
[Music]